hello welcome to this video this is
coverage of round eight of the Tata
Steel 2016 tournament a little bit late
again but I'm happy to keep those those
updates on in the first place is a bit
difficult at the moment so let's get
going we've got the game Wesley so with
one against shock magyar off yep can an
Italian game no not many balloons in
this event they try all kinds of things
to avoid it starting on with one in most
cases but what did we get here we get
them quiet treatment with d3 and c3 but
pretty early on um so is coming up with
something quite unusual night 2 a 3 yeah
the idea is probably too yeah reroute
the night as it is often happening but
do that why is this move water instead
of like d2f one yeah I'm not sure if
this is sown a big issue but it's it's a
new idea Mammadyarov plays some in a
very logical fashion exactly to be
honest I play exactly the same against
the setup I mean not night III this is a
move I never saw it let's say white good
play like 92 f 1 and said I would play
exactly the same as black does llego age
6 rook e8 and Bishop you six I think
this is a very clean way of playing with
black and the only issue is that it's
absolutely difficult to ever win a game
it is a super sound super solid but how
to ever do something is beyond me in
this game we had the typical scenario
the bishops get traded and white get
Cindy for um Teague's takes and now an
interesting little moment Black has to
avoid to take on e4 with the rook looks
tempting to grab that central pawn but
at the end this is a pretty awkward
double attack 95 there's before and all
of a sudden like magic
this night has a useful post wide
windsor full piece of all porn but it's
enough to win the game so mayara I've
had to take them and play this position
yeah and here on white is a little bit
more comfortable because of the space
because it's 93 to a 593 to d5 you can
reroute that the night is actually
pretty well placed on see to him it's
not not bad the issue is however that
blacks pollution is super solid that
some absolutely difficult to break down
and Norma jar of defense is so quiet I
think confidently as I said there's not
much that black hands to fear in many of
those positions just that you cannot do
much ever and in this game they renew it
a little bit here but yeah now so
decided to call it a day with nitin f5
this is at the end just to draw yeah
black ski is somewhat okay and it's a
perpetual check check yeah what we need
tried with this he takes after trying to
get the point of six but it does not not
happen okay you have to give the check
f6 there is rook e1 and why does even
losing yeah a very solid game let's say
from both sides but ultimately not not
much happening and the next game I'm
going to look at is ding Liren against
why here Chinese door and this in my
mind but this is just my personal
opinion is just as interesting as the
game before not much to be honest it was
um it just looks different um why do I
say that because well it's a super-sharp
game but also a game that both sides
probably had on them on their notebooks
at home it's all pretty much known and
yeah we would see what happens that
knight c6 line is it's an interesting
sideline against
the Russian system with queen bee three
one point said after Bishop b2 Black is
going 45 an interesting line I looked at
this some years ago actually for ya for
both sides actually I was thinking about
the gruene fraud with blackened against
the Russian system some sideline would
have been well covered I'll end it with
this but at the time it was a new new
line and nowadays it is explored quite
well taking naija form is completely
fine for black you get the point back
easily so d5 is critical and now 94 yeah
black jumps right in it's a yeah in fact
um very forced White has to take that
night and now take the pawn there's no
choice and now c6 black is attacking the
center and you threatening night XD 5 in
the process in the early days of that
line there were a couple of tries with
d6 but this nowadays is pretty much
diffused by rookie eighth green d3 and
b5 and this all looks very sharp and
spectacular but if you check it a little
bit with the computer you'll see that
black will get d6 back and just has an
active position in the game it's even
more spectacular after Quincy form like
as yeah sacrificing even and even 11
extra porn [ __ ] 11 more porn on c6
White has a take should be 726 and now
rookie I'd notice the time yeah both
sides have blitz this out and it's not
even inconceivable that they have looked
at this together i am at some point
because the chinese players tend to work
together very closely so it's a yeah
it's it's just very sharp a very
spectacular looking but they know what
they're doing and they just play what
they had at home Queen a 3 yeah there
was a game relatively recent was g3
which is also interesting thing is if
you give it to a comp it says 000 pretty
if you Gillette it running a little bit
yeah before like is tossing in another
pawn rupee 823 takes on the form yeah
and now the queen age for IDM is of
course looming and the best whitening is
f form check no checking taking yeah I
know ding was actually spending time
maybe he was trying to recall something
that that he had to look that looked at
earlier the thing is um the way it goes
Bishop f2 Queen 83 Bishop takes and this
this is a position if you give it to an
engine again it just zeros out it just
zeros out and ye was in prep he was just
blitzing everything and ding was
thinking maybe he was trying to remember
that some way out of this what he did
now is very understandable then repeated
moves them and the game ended so for me
a kind of a non game as they both had it
in their prep the whole time maybe ding
was trying to figure out if there's some
way out of whatever or if he had to
recall everything um yeah why is it a
draw at this moment or why did they
repeat it is very difficult for white to
avoid it um you can try for example to
Castle long it looks dangerous instantly
and it's actually probably losing now
here the bishop is hanging and if white
covers this move Bishop and five given
by the comp and here the attack will get
very very very tough to defend or I mean
White's losing I'm phrasing this wrong
there is no way out him actually what is
the threat if white is playing I'm not
quite sure what why should do because he
has his tight
down a lot let's say some Queen move for
example then there's III and now the
thread this rooks III and Group B one
made alternatively Queen to you for can
be a move it's just a fantastic attack
so wyd cannot cancel all that loses the
engine for a while wants to play rook g1
covering that Queen g2 thing but then
ultimately the computer also zeroes out
after Bishop tea for you can look at
this little bit with yourself if you
like with with a computer and toy around
but then it's very difficult for y to do
anything else and then taking the draw i
think i'm especially in a practical game
taking the draw as a very wise decision
as you're probably going to get killed
if you try to survive such a position
against somebody who has used absolutely
no time okay so spectacular on the
outside but it's not not that one not
that much happened to you ok the next
game i want to check is kayaking with
white against Magnus Carlsen we got a
little pest and Carleton Place g6 and
quite interesting line that he has used
them on and off over the years not often
maybe like twice a year sometimes but it
is quite decent black wants to obviously
if you encounter with the bishop and
cover the e5 pawn in that way white
still cannot win a pawn with this as we
know from the a6 line so what is why
doing him two main options wide can play
with c3 castles in either order or you
can open up the center with deform i
actually have look at the Atlas line
myself but with black but what I never
really liked is the move deform this is
not objectively so dangerous but I never
liked the idea of having to play Bishop
e7 year after half play g6 it's not it's
not a big deal actually but I never
liked this kind of position so much as
felt like white is slightly better of it
maybe Carlton is some believing
that you can defend such a position
easily which might be true well what we
get is this position which also could
arise from the stein its defense or
deferred steinitz with a six and d6 um
that leads to a kind of interesting play
I think this is something that I feel
like black players could investigate you
have to get a Spanish type of position
but it has a king's indian type of
flavor yeah here with black sometimes
getting in at five cars whatever has an
entirely different idea after the move
Bishop e3 um he goes for the amazing
move Knight to g8 just undeveloped Inge
hit the night yeah what's the point he
wants to get rid of the bishop here with
Bishop to h6 yeah that Bishop is not
looking great on g7 but so that is a
long long time that you spend there to
get rid of that piece um it doesn't seem
to be bad it's just it's not a new idea
in a sense it has been tried before but
but still it's a very rare idea and kind
kind of funny yeah okay so black gets
rid of the bishop and just place this
position yeah the virtue of that trade
is twofold the bishop wasn't great in
the first place looking at his pawns but
also black traded pieces which is very
helpful as you have little space here
and i think this position is something
that um it's somewhat similar to
position that i sometimes get out of the
bog winyan or other players get out of
the book indian um and my usual feeling
is that when you get down to two minor
pieces per site that is helps and this
is the case here two nights for both
sides I think however that not not sure
but I think what kayaking is doing the
next couple of
isn't so testing even though I cannot
really give a clear improvement he
played Roxy one after which cousin got
in that a five move and got the a file
open and I felt that this help black a
little bit but I'm not quite sure what
else why should do it you can start with
92 and so on but maybe it's not a big
difference the way it went he got the a
file and played interesting moves now
not to be 6 that's an interesting move
it doesn't look very typical to put the
nut on b6 but it has a point it looks at
this pawn so that the night cannot move
c5 is not possible anyway because the
queen is on that square at least it
doesn't promise about anything um and
what black is doing is he takes some
control over the a8 square so then
whenever there is a trade on the AFL
he's quickly replacing this rook now
he's going for c6 that's important to
understand then black quite often goes
for c6 in such a structure to gain a
little bit of space and this also is
what happened to him he got there ok
Aidan and now went 46 and around here I
think black is perfectly fine he now has
the idea in some cases to play c5 and ok
it's difficult to imagine black playing
for wynia but if you get in like see 5y
plus B 5 and then you play C 5 p-5 then
you can play this and queen a8 maybe you
can do something on the iphone very
unlikely though so white decided to take
that's the easiest solution here covered
c4 and here they found this this
pendulum maneuver and agree to a draw I
think this is a very okay decision
because both sides have a hard time to
do anything the White Nights here they
are kind of tied to defend the pawns in
and what sometimes can happen is some
trade of C against d point after which
that
is completely lifeless so pretty correct
draw here i think carlton getting equal
play quite effortlessly effortlessly
with this offbeat line here with this
funny idea 98 but it seems to be viable
yeah it's the position is very close and
it seemed to be perfectly okay okay so
next game to check is Giri thomashefsky
and geary is going for some reti opening
here with c4 and yeah I'm happy to to
tell you that I actually have some
experience with this position I've
played this position quite a bit over
the years and then various situations
time controls I've had a classical games
for example with now it takes takes
queen bee three and I actually believe
that this is stronger than what give me
played um oh sorry d3 first we should be
seven queen bee thesis what I have
played more than once I I think that
this is a very interesting type of
structure with the white going 9380 for
later um I think it's an interesting way
to play a little bit more interesting
than what what gear eat ride him he went
for something comparable 23 queen bee 63
night pg7 and yeah here we come to it to
the interesting moment here what white
astride quite a bit as Bishop e3 this
more but Giri goes for the trade on d5
if he if black no takes with the e porn
I think then he would have retreated and
gotten to the position I have just
talked about um Tomashevsky ever
captured on b3e traded and now we get
this this position um I think I mean
Giri was I think aiming exactly for what
he got in the game and it's an
interesting way to play it's not like
completely pointless of course not I
just feel that it is that doesn't have
enough bite he wanted to go for that put
the porn on before and play this kind of
position where white has some chances to
either use a 5c form or deform a 5c 544
yeah the black Queen side is slightly
weak a knight coming to a five for
example could be pretty annoying the
other thing that why it can go for in
some cases is to play the movie form of
circumstances are right to potentially
after details details get a for porn
against three porn majority on the
queenside a on the King side I'm sorry
that you can push forward we see some of
that later in the game but should be
seven and that looks very logical yeah
white gets his pieces to control d 4 + C
5 and now he goes f4 gaining some space
and this is what I was talking about if
white manages to get in something like
e4 e5 then he has some play but it's
difficult to do blacks way of defending
this is to defend to prevent this kind
of advance and the way it went might
never got it in and why just gaining
more space here on the Kings side but we
see that d 6 is a great square for the
night it looks at all the critical
squares like efore p5 the bishop on c8
is actually well-placed it covers b7 if
it is attacked some day it is covered
and before it's not possible yeah here
we tried with this structure but still
the key is to being able to play for and
then was never possible you know it was
you shuffling channeling this was traded
the beef I was opened but they on that
same the the range of roughly quality
was never really left it was just about
equal the whole time I mean if anybody
why does a little bit more comfortable
so I see why give me try it around a
little bit but
fast-forward mode doesn't really hurt
him not much happened not much happened
so I think a very sound and solid game
by by thomashefsky give us idea here
with going with a BB porn it's certainly
playable and quite ok but it doesn't
seem to have enough bite to ultimately
post yeah post big problems ok um the
next game I want to look at is what
which one actually let's go who your
phone fan really it's a it's not the
next couple of games are interesting um
so who you find she had a really good
event but lost then a game against
Mammadyarov where she was equal know so
she sources down fifty percent now but
maybe she can do something with white
against when really who's yea struggling
in the event expected the SES the
underdog okay got a sharp night off he
and when Vinny is sticking yeah to his
to his guns here with with e6 not going
for Nigel for anything like that okay
she goes gee for this is the sharpest
line in this position absolutely um
black here can go for a five-night f5 g6
after which why does often sacrificing
stuffed with g5 it's super super sharp
line is at g5 I actually wonder well I
think it is right it's not my kind of
line but I think g5 is right and but I
mean really didn't do that you bet h6
slightly more conservative way of
playing this okay queenie of three bahu
you find white has a couple of options
but this is this is one of them she has
played this before um night bg7 by when
really taking control of 85 and hear a
move Queen g2 was played not the most
common placement for the Queen but yeah
95 while a threat you have to move it
probably and this is having this in mind
each one
five yeah when really now stop the mochi
five with g5 himself yeah pretty radical
but kind of kind of usual in this
structure you want to make sure that you
have apology files to capture any F porn
pushes and it secures that square on e5
as a yeah as a defensive stronghold yeah
she went with age form it's all very
logical route g8 takes tags and this is
a critical position now and what will
you find how is playing is leading to
mmm yeah I think somewhat let's say
dynamic equality something like that it
sir it's um not bad but not a not a
critical test maybe of blacks position I
mean blacks position is certainly um
looking slightly dubious out and say it
may be slightly so I mean development
wise is somewhat behind and it looks
like white may have attacking chances
against the black king on the other hand
it's clear that blacks long-term
prospects are excellent if he's not
getting getting killed in the next
couple of moves then this night only
five will be great this dark square
control is good and he has ideas with
before on the queenside it's kind of a
now-or-never situation in a way for what
why it should be quick trying to do
things um the move that was suggested
during the broadcast source Bishop takes
25 and I think this is really
interesting even though it's difficult
to to get a clear picture how this is to
be assessed if black takes it and of
course f4 was the idea and here the
situation is totally unclear to me after
black place this move yeah takes 9 to e
three green g3 and something like this
and this and let's say queen to d6 it's
not completely for stem but situation
here is unclean
to me a black from a structural point of
view is an excellent shape with the two
bishops and everything but he also still
has this issue with the King and Dwight
can maybe shoot for pressure on f7 black
doesn't have a clear idea what to do
with this king um I really don't know
what just has it it's very interesting
though um after Bishop takes you five
black can also play before and just
sacrifice this pawn in a way because
this position is also quite interesting
like a threatening Bishop d7 for example
many opportunities but Bishop g5 looks
like critical critical test she played
nadia 3 which is not as it not bad but
it doesn't seem to test black that much
now e5 is the idea and here before was
the only way now for black to deal with
this situation we got this
transformation now and here the material
is equal but blacks position it seems is
somewhat easier to play he's got the two
bishops and a very strong potential
pressure on the long diagonal it seems
that white is not in in terrible shape
but black seems to be easier to play and
maybe a somewhat better somewhat later
there was one opportunity that who you
fun head but she did not take and we
will see what happened in this position
after a five she had a tactical shot
available that that she didn't see of
course the position is difficult on
tricky to play but white has to take
this opportunity um if she doesn't do it
and we see what happened in the game
then very easily a blacks position can
become overwhelming one reason is that
this bishop on g4 is not really doing
much it just looks at a well-protected
pawn on d6 and other than that um
didn't have any particular purpose what
she should do is some of a five yeah
after Bishop cakes why does you check
quickly winning the game now this is not
going to end beautifully for black so
after this this one has to be played and
now White has a very strong x95 very
interesting the point is that you open
up the D file for Queen d7 and if black
plays something like that there is this
strong all of a sudden attacking here
yes is also a fork after Queen takes and
black it probably has to do that can we
get this and after Queen e7 whitens
excellent chances to draw the game yeah
the activity is pretty strong and there
are a couple of lines there that are
immensely immensely computer ish but
quite quite funny for example here the
computer wants to play route to h6 and
after let's say if black plays I know
let's dance to something like that I
just want to show an idea here then the
computer gives this as a draw because it
takes this rook h7 very weird sequence
and after this there are this the
perpetual checks cannot cannot be
prevented very weird line but if I was
it also was kind of logically I tried to
shut down the bishop and get get the
activity going after Queen age too she
took a while to play that move however
when Venus is firmly in the in the
driver's seat this this and Bishop a6
and this is the issue that night is not
stable anymore now and if the night gets
traded the bishop it's immensely strong
on the beach
square yeah this is what happened and
here we go no black is attacking with
extra pieces as the bishop on g4 is
there is an absolute spectator doing
nothing at all yeah and with both sides
being the one time they really manages a
good check mop-up job he's an exchange
up and also has an has an attack so a
good win ear for the Dutch I think it's
the Dutch number two right it's nobody
yeah the van valen first win that he
scores in that in that event a tough
game for who you found maybe she was a
bit so a little bit of her game after
that unnecessary loss against the
mamedyarov you don't know it was very
difficult though very difficult to play
position when really was going for his
usual sharp night off and many of those
decisions are very difficult to take I
mean if I'm just go back here that
decision what to play in this position
is very very tough to make and it also
not clear that Bishop g5 was any good
I'm just I showed a couple of lines but
they were absolutely not conclusive it
can easily be that it is it is also
equal or kind of okay let's say for for
black but it seems to be a much tougher
test though okay let's go for the final
two games um what am I going to check
first I'm going for Adams early enough
um and here i want to focus on some
spots in the end game it was an end came
quickly because we have the berlin wall
and games something that we I think have
not seen yet in the tournament um
yeah so what happened in this game I'm
not an expert on this opening but I can
tell you that a leonov's way of playing
this was Bishop e7 and later 92 h4 it's
not particularly popular he has done
that before and with success I mean
draws him but um so it couldn't come as
a surprise for Adams however in the game
I think and what we see is all those
moves look fairly fairly normal we see
that after f5 which is an interesting
radical idea to to open up the position
quickly that black is already very
comfortable so slightly mysterious for
me what happened after 14 moves I mean
black is usually getting good results in
the in the Berlin but he has to suffer a
little bit a little bit at least in many
cases and here he was immediately fine
I'm in this position white naught took
cakes and here it's already I think
pretty apparent how comfortable blackest
he will get in some f5 and his bishop s
is very nice in that open position so
some of this there needs to be some kind
of improvement as we made here for Wyatt
um and f5 that was that that's what i
was talking about like is opening up the
position very very quickly yeah what is
why it's supposed to do with this
bishops get activated especially those
pawns can become vulnerable if you think
about bishop coming there yeah in this
phase of the game white was struggling a
lot that's keeping keeping the game
going that same and yeah Alienor had a
very nice position played here to see
form in our bedroom f3 it might be that
Bishop f5
the bad move it's a bit looks a bit
cold-blooded you're putting it in on the
f file but white has no discovery and
the idea is sometimes to go Bishop to
you for it's not quite clear what he
didn't like about the move I think black
seems to be in excellent shape here the
best that what can do is probably to
take and play something like that but
here black is really just a pawn up and
if we look at the game he tried this
this part will ultimately get lost and
this means we we have a very comparable
position and maybe it didn't see 93
that's possible that deal of trick or
the Sun threatening here and if black
takes as Luke f3 and here black skin
gets actor but wyd wins the pawn however
we have to give credit to iron ore
familiarize everything yeah the king is
marching all the way all the way here
and tries to win the Queen side and this
is actually what happened H porn was
going no night to d2 that seems to be
okay it just tries to shut out the
bishop even though age six also what's
possible and probably will lead to an
equal position something like a Bishop
d3 let's say um h7 king edge 895 and
Bishop c2 yeah just about you have to
have to give it up to stop the H polish
should end in a draw what Adams plane
also was okay it's very sharp don't we
have black as material up but the h1 is
running check nidus is entering the game
and the H point will run yet here we
come to a critical critical moment here
Adams with very precise play can draw
the game even though is three points
down Knight to f4 would have been the
move to find there's some logic behind
that you cover this or you intend to go
there to push the edge porn home and the
way it went something like that could
have been the could have been the
consequence check check and black has a
hard time to make any headway something
like this is 93 and now you start to
pick up pawns black cannot do this
checkmate yeah yeah and this is a draw I
we can can try to find something with
with the computer the abbot's you it
just gives 000 come on to play mate
check Black has to jettison this to not
get in checkmated end here something
like that we'll all gently litany to a
draw check this is the the end very long
line but the thing is you have to see it
in comparison to the game in the game NM
scopus 94 and that does not work the
draw 55 check now the night is just far
away from them the pawn and here the
pawns advance much quicker no there's no
night be to mate now no came to
battalion I 24 check all very logical
yeah and here on move 58 um okay there's
more than one leaf that wins but here
rook takes h7 was a very convincing way
for Ali enough to win the game why just
take black takes the night and now those
pawns promote its no way for why to stop
them a couple of moves later check there
was here he again could have taken on
age seven but didn't
and here it's a little bit different but
there is no discovered check that is in
any way any way a problem if why it
takes this rook h3s is decisive check
here and this cannot be stopped okay you
played Bishop f5 it stood still wins of
course but there are some opportunities
of doing pretty clean job down but
didn't it didn't go for that yeah we've
concentrated black I still three pawns
up check and now King you form and this
looks totally normal but it seems to
spoil it King to be king to d2 it's
probably still winning it's tricky
already but it's probably still wins
after this and now the bishop comes back
to save this and this point is also safe
yeah by the rook tough very tough fun to
play that kind of game and done then
after king e for all of a sudden it is
the draw and white is getting that pawn
and now there is no way forward those
pawns are blocked you tried a little bit
more of course but it's impossible now
to win chan chan the night is just a
complete blockade on and here the two
pawns are irrelevant this is a block on
the leaf I'll and blackheads no way
forward a very disappointing end to this
game to alien awful really plate I think
a very good fighting game we had some
then impossibilities probably in an
early end game transition but then he
played also in a very fighting way going
all the way to a three and going for the
sharpest possible approach but at the
end he missed two clear chances to to
mop it up and then yeah one mistake cost
the game ever the winner was
draw at the end but very disappointing
finish turn before the Ukrainian number
one yeah it's the number one of Ukraine
at the mode okay I'm let last game for
that round final game to Lucas navara
with white against Cara wanna and we got
a new zone and Navarro is going for very
safe line you Quincy to another three ya
see 596 is the prescribed anti dote and
this kind of line is not see text in
situ e-form um has been in fashion a
little bit for quite a while to go for
this and one reason is that this is a
very safe line for white that despite
its weak looking porn structure is safe
because I'm to the 65 white has this
activity this bishop and this bishop
will often come to a forum and black
quite often has to be very precise to
equalize this and often the Equality
will be very equal so there is no time
let's say for black to conveniently play
at those pawns it's it's really
difficult to do so 97 was played as also
98 it's also possibility and this kind
of variation here I think Ruby ate that
was I think criticized by young
gustafson as being a little bit
uncomfortable for black and it actually
it's what happened in the game I think
that this is a bit uncomfortable for
black I think Guzan wanted like to take
only five if i'm not mistaken but don't
quite remember clearly but if that group
b 8 wasn't wasn't the best and i think
this game confirms that blacks play he
is not easy you played v6c five and six
why was taking near nice little tricky
and rook
cannot be taken so here and now rupee to
was played and in the game played just a
couple of days before this game between
the Italian player basso and Yosef hora
Bartram from Hungary a bustle played
rookie three instead of Ruby too and
also had a slight advantage with f4 and
the problem is a little bit that black
is yeah black is somewhat passive you
cannot easily develop his Bishop and
wide rooks are more active it's not
convenient to play and I'll said very
safe for what um navara played rookie to
whatever i'm king to f7 like a while I
was taking time is really playing here
now Navarro plays f4 after long think
and after five immediately captured only
five and this is quite amazing because
it looks like a blunders in exchange
yeah Bishop to g4 yeah develop yeah I
didn't overlook that that's kind of
impossible to believe so he willingly
gave up the exchange and the following
sequence is really a bit mysterious he
tries ecigs that was the idea now of
course here black has to go to g6 King
u7s roop t7 and Bishop takes it's not
not the idea let's say if you want to
win they exchange here so kick to g6
Bishop before church at that always
played quickly also by Navarro so the
mysterious part now is here and here
kawana plate after quite some thought
the move f5 and I'm surprised that he
did that because um I mean okay
everybody sees that King h6 is keeping
the exchange it's the normal move to
play in a way and I was I was really
surprised that he didn't do that because
it's clear that wide
compensation that's it's really clear
it's not just a flat exchange what has a
pawn anyway and the e porn is dangerous
however if you look at like something
that King f2 went well black Teague's
and please let's say rook c8 um it's I
think pretty clear that the e pawn will
not promote quickly and if that doesn't
is that isn't the case I think then
black pretty much has to go for that
then because also what he did if you
look at what he did I think that this is
I mean engines give black a slight
advantage I'm not sure maybe white has
enough for the exchange but it seems
that this is the far more playable
position than what he did he played f5
and all there's a seven you know
attacking the rook yeah and we have this
transformation now navara actually take
it I didn't know that at least that's
given here I don't know if he if he took
with if you really a promoter to look
funny yeah anyway the position here that
was it was pretty clear that this arises
by force after that f5 move by epic
arowana and this position to be honest
absolutely sucks for black you have an
immensely passive position and white has
clear ideas is going to go up with a
king es got two points against one so
there are always potential breakthroughs
the bishop on d5 is controlling a eight
so that the a porn can be very dangerous
and the Seaport also is controlled at CA
de that promotion square is also
controlled by the bishop and blacks
counter plays non-existent we look at
what happens blacks position is
absolutely terrible to play then white
has easy ideas may comes up to the king
here yeah and black is just sitting
there and well
I rather take that exchange up and play
this position which is also not very
attractive maybe but it's this is just a
torture um I absolutely cannot tell you
if black could afford that could have
helped the position um the way it went
navara was some yeah poking around all
the times is the way you play this just
doing little things and improve improve
improve a little bit and there was a
critical moment a little bit later and
this is coming coming here here black
head to play King to d8 which is not
very happy move but you have to you have
to play that um what can one a plate
loses he took on g3 and after that um
now um now when Navarro has a has an
excellent sequence that wins the game
you played a 56 and c5 and now this is
the thing the sea porn is is coming up
the board g6 is the threat and black has
no way to defend against the chair it's
no good still c6 coming yeah he tried
King to d8 but now wyd wins with this
nice sequence age 5 this covers the g6
um square and for King to the six black
has no check yeah now we see the problem
the sea point is coming and after this
there's also this nice move threatening
c7 mate and that was that was the final
move of the game Caruana reside an
excellent game by Navarro really i've
really liked it um the thing is there
was this kind of open question why why
didn't koala
keep the exchange um I'm not saying it
was terribly easy to do I anything like
that I don't want to be too critical
there just that if we if we revisit that
moment again check that here after f5
the sequences relatively force and the
position is very uncomfortable and this
is not so clear actually how does white
play it with the pawn and especially in
modern chance you have this attitude too
and like show me yeah i'm taking the
material you have to show me why it does
not work and yeah in this game caruana
didn't didn't go for that for that yeah
show me attitude and he should have done
so it seems in the in the game the
position was very difficult to defend
may be impossible to defend and under
that typical situation of the clock
ticking and not having unlimited time
and resources or whatever it just makes
it so more much more difficult ok I hope
you enjoyed the coverage of round eight
I'll be back with round nine coverage
bye bye